hello my name is Antoine Victor and I'll
be your instructor for this DevOps
training in this training we're looking
at what is DevOps the DevOps lifecycle
DevOps
tools talked a little bit about version
control and then we'll get into CI and
CD that's continuous integration and
continuous delivery and then we'll
follow on with configuration management
containerization and finally finishing
up there with monitoring so let's go
ahead and dive right in with a
definition of DevOps so what is DevOps
really well DevOps largely is a cultural
shift
it's an organization wide cultural shift
towards delivering business value to the
end customer now this means that
development and operations both have to
work together now because DevOps is a
clipped compound which includes only
development and operations it might seem
like DevOps is just for developers and
operation staff but the reality is if we
were to include everything that DevOps
really contained DevOps
containing development operations
obviously but also quality assessment
security configuration management
infrastructure management network
management and so on and so on and so on
the the name wouldn't sound cool it
would be a good marketing term anyway
anymore so let's assume for now that
DevOps includes not just development and
operations but everything on the
software delivery pipeline from idea to
business value making it into the
customers hands so developers
continuously want to develop and test
code so they're building new features
they're rewarded for delivering new
features to the end customer on the
other hand the operations team is in
charge of keeping the network and the
production software in a running State
so for them less changes are better so
you can see we've got kind of opposing
missions here between development
operations development wants to deliver
new features but the operation of
delivering new features tends to cause
downtime which the operations team are
rewarded for maintaining the opposite of
that which is uptime so in order to get
these guys working together the
development team and the operations team
working together to enable continuous
deployment
we have to automate a lot of these his
store
clean manual processes so what we're
really talking about here is the DevOps
lifecycle or the software delivery life
cycle will be plan and again because
we're talking about the entire team
working together here we're planning but
not planning everything we plan just
enough to get get the next iteration
done and then we code but just enough to
complete the features that we plan to
deliver in the coming release and then
we compile or build that solution and
once we get a successful build of that
solution then we go on and test that
solution and only on successful
completion of all of those tests do we
move on to the next phase where we
integrate the code that one team member
has just submitted got a successful
build on and then a successful test run
then we take that code and we integrate
it with all the code that was written by
the other developers on the team and
then we test it again and once we are
successful with that integrated build
and that integrated test run then we can
move on to configuring the environment
that we're going to deploy this
successfully compiled and tested
solution to that's where configuration
management comes into play it's best to
avoid configuration drift and incorrect
configurations by automating this
process of configuring those servers
that we're going to deploy our solution
to so with configuration management and
automated configuration our goal is to
automate this process so we can be more
consistent and reliable and once we've
configured the system that we're going
to then we want to use automated
deployment to deploy to those systems
that have been configured in a
consistent way well now we want to now
deploy them in a consistent and reliable
way and finally once those solutions are
deployed successfully into our stable
consistently configured environment we
want to monitor the ongoing use of those
solutions to make sure that users are
getting the features and the performance
that they expect from the solution that
we've delivered so let's start at the
beginning let's say we want to build a
website for a company we might have a
customer that comes to us and says hey I
want to build a new website for my
organization and we might respond you
know you can use DevOps tools and
techniques to build your website and
streamline your delivery process hey
that's
like a great idea let's do it so let me
hire some developers testers and
operations guys who can develop and test
them and maintain the website and then
after gathering all the requirements the
developers can start building the code
for the website and store each version
of that code in a source code repository
but for now level call it github we'll
say we're using github so we've got a
couple of developers and we've got our
github repository to store all of our
solution artifacts so at this point
we've done a little bit of the planning
we've collected some requirements for
our customer we've started on the coding
we've stored some of the code in our
local git repository or maybe we're
using the Microsoft stack and we might
be using the tool formerly known as team
foundation services it's now called as
your DevOps but as far as source control
using the same foundations as git so we
get our code into version control you
might have multiple files that the
developers have created developers are
working on file1 file2 file 3 and they
check those files in the github
repository as version 1 another team of
developers might be working on different
features that might impact those same
files so they're working on file 3 but
have made a couple of versions of it a
couple of iterations to it so they're on
file 3.3 while team one is only on file
3 as we merge those different branches
of changes together we create version 2
of the solution but if anything goes
wrong anywhere along the way we have
kept those branches of changes separate
so one will not affect the other this is
the benefit of version control and
source control tools like git and github
so the basic architecture of get here we
have a working directory we've got a
local staging area where we prepare
changes that we've made to be committed
to the local repository and then to
share those changes with other
developers on the team we can push the
changes out to a remote repository to
receive changes that other developers
have made or other team members have
made we can pull those changes down from
the remote repository so back to our
website project here now the developers
have built the code using whatever tools
they chose to use whether they be dotnet
Eclipse or some other editing tool we
can then
take that code and make sure that code
is valid by compiling it packaging it
and then having the code verified by our
quality assurance team now in order for
other team members to access this code
it's best if it's moved to that central
repository the github that we were
talking about earlier so our developers
write their code they compile it make
sure it runs and the tests all pass
locally and they can push that out to
our central repository in github now
we've talked about planning and we
talked about testing and we've talked
about the compiling and the source code
repository but we didn't really talk
about how that compiling is being done
so one of the ways that we might build
Java code is by using a tool called
maven now maven is what we can use to
define how our build is going to be done
and automate our build process so once
we have that planning and building phase
done our solution has been tested and
stored in version control we might want
to run some additional tests for that we
need the testers the testers are going
to test the code that we built to make
sure there are no errors that perhaps
weren't caught by our automated testing
that was part of the development process
so the testers are going to perform
functional tests they may rerun some of
the unit tests created by the developers
system tests and user acceptance tests
to fully vet the solution to make sure
that it's ready for primetime
so again at this point we've done a
little bit of planning we've done some
coding we've done some building of that
code and some automated unit testing of
that code and now we've passed it off to
the QA team so they can do more
exhaustive testing of that solution now
some of the additional tests that the QA
team might run would be UI automation
tests exploratory tests smoke tests to
find issues that may not have been
exposed by the low level testing unit
testing that developers may have done
during the development process using
test-driven development
once the QA team has finished doing that
additional testing making sure that we
didn't miss anything with our automated
testing process then the operations team
will need to integrate those changes
along with anything that's already out
there in production maybe a previous
version of the solution existing data
from an old database or what have you we
can use continuous integration to make
sure that all that code all those
changes that are being made by different
team members is compiled and tested and
deployed together on the production
servers in a consistent way so again
we've gone from planning to developing
or coding rather and building that code
and testing that code to integrating
those changes with changes that the
other developers on the team have made
and finally running additional tests and
after all of our tests are passed
pushing that solution out to production
servers or production like servers as we
prepare for additional tests like load
and stress tests now this operation this
automation process of moving these
resources out into the QA environment
and on into the pre-production staging
environments and finally off into
production
there are several tools that we can use
to automate this process some of the
more common tools listed here on the
slide
Jenkins bamboo and Travis CI that's
continuous integration and of course
Azure DevOps not here on the slide so a
common example of using CI and CDN
Jenkins as again we have our developers
doing their work hopefully writing their
tests first so when they complete their
work they can commit their work to our
source code repository and that act of
committing the work the source code
repository can cause a tool like Jenkins
to automatically fire off a continuous
integration trigger to build that
solution test that solution and if it
passes potentially deploy that solution
off to the next environment but if it
fails we can reject that check in to the
repository and send notification back to
the developer or other team member that
introduced that defect allowing them to
fix that defect before it causes any
problems for other team members now of
course if that build and that test run
passes then Jenkins can automatically
move that change that version of the
solution on to the next environment by
that next environment in this case is
the QA environment where now the testers
have access to that solution and the
testers can perform more exhaustive
exploratory testing
user acceptance testing and so forth if
they then find any errors then they can
push that feedback back down to the
development team who can then fix those
issues and then resubmit that code
through the continuous integration
pipeline
now if the testers don't find any
defects then they would promote or
approve that solution for promotion into
the production environment or again we
might have a more complex environment
where we push from QA into a staging
environment where we then continue to
run load and stress testing so so far in
our CI CV pipeline here we have the
developers making the changes we have
the developers pushing those changes
into a code repository like git we have
the build system or the continuous
integration system like Jenkins
detecting that change and get and then
automatically compiling and testing
those changes submitted by the developer
and on the test framework side we have
unit tests which are most likely written
by the developers as they're writing the
code or before they write the code if
we're using test-driven or test-first
development and then we have web UI
testing done with tools like selenium
and then integration testing which could
be additional unit tests run with those
UI tests and other acceptance tests on
our integration server now as we move on
from continuous integration to
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment there are other tools that we
can employ like Serena and pivotal CF as
well as Google's cloud platform Adger
and Amazon's AWS to assist in this
automation of delivery and deployment so
a textbook definition of continuous
delivery is to be ready and able to
deploy any version of our solution to
any supported platform at any time
continuous deployment is basically the
same thing but without the ready and
able with continuous deployment as the
name implies you are continuously
deploying every change that successfully
makes it through compile and test
automatically to the production
environment or at least to a production
slot whereas continuous delivery we're
just ready to deploy because we've done
all of our compiling and testing maybe
even we've done
more exploratory testing manual testing
and even some automated load and stress
testing but in any event the solution is
ready to be deployed it's just not
deployed yet with continuous delivery
with continuous deployment as the name
implies we have actually deployed a
solution so now the solution is deployed
the Operations team is going to want to
make sure the systems and deploy the
code on to the production environment in
a consistent way for that we need a
configuration management to help make
sure the systems are configured in a
consistent state and functioning
properly for the version of the software
that's about to be deployed this avoids
configuration drift and incorrectly
configured devices using a configuration
tool like ansible puppet or chef we can
make sure that the configuration happens
automatically in a consistent way so
every deployment is either successful or
fails the exact same way it failed last
time because the failure was part of the
automation some DevOps tools that we can
use for these configuration operations
our puppet docker chef and ansible now
these tools are the most common tools
used for this deployment and
configuration automation phase of our
DevOps delivery pipeline so again
configuration management is the process
of systematically managing and handling
changes to a system in a way that
maintains integrity over time how does
it do that you might ask well it does
that by doing the configuration in the
automated and consistent way so the same
way we take our code and we compile it
we test it and make sure that it's
passed those tests and compile
successfully we can take our
configuration and do that in the same
automated way and once we have a
configuration automation script that
works successfully we can then take that
configuration automation script that
playbook that recipe or what have you
and store it in the source code
repository along with the rest of the
solution artifacts the code and any
documentation that we might have
collected or created over time and put
it in that central source of truth
github or our central repository or
whatever tool that you choose now we
have everything either in our artifact
repository that would be
output of our build our deployment
package or in our source code repository
resolved our source code documents
configuration files and so forth we have
a central source of truth for all of the
resources necessary to successfully
deploy this solution so even if we had
nothing more than our source code
repository our artifact repository and
their mental resources we could
reproduce this solution so puppets an
open source configuration management
tool for deploying managing and
configuring multiple servers in an
automated way very consistent so we
basically have the notion of nodes for
the puppets if you will that are
controlled by the puppet master so what
basically happens here is the node sends
the data about itself to the puppet
master the puppet uses that information
to compile a catalog that shows how that
node is supposed to be configured but if
over time something changes and that
node reports back to the puppet master
that the configuration is incorrect
incomplete or has changed something
that's non-standard then the puppet
master can then push down updated
configuration to keep that server in a
standard state consistent with its store
configuration and all the other nodes
that are necessary for that solution to
run as far as deployment to these
different servers and configured
resources an easy way to make sure that
deployment is consistent is to really
avoid the redundant configuration and
deployment of those solutions to
multiple servers individually by
deploying into a container and then
using that container to replicate that
configuration across multiple devices
and resources containerization is
basically the process that allows
software to run reliably when move from
one computing environment to another
because it's not dependent on the local
computing environment itself rather on
the container host if you will basically
a virtual machine requires that we use
up a lot of resources and install a full
copy of the operating system inside of
that virtual machine and that virtual
machine basically needs all the same
hardware
that the operating system needs to run
containers on the other hand live inside
of that post machine and effectively are
segmented from all of that hardware and
requirements of having a full operating
system they're basically small
containers inside of the existing
operating system so we get the same
level of isolation without all the
overhead requirements of having a full
virtual machine with installed operating
system this allows us to easily deploy
the containers without all the headaches
of installing an operating system and
redoing the configuration so docker
containers are basically standard units
of software that package the code and
all of their dependencies so that the
application runs faster and it's
reliable from one computing environment
to another again because it's not
dependent on the underlying hardware or
even the underlying operating system but
just a container host so the operations
team verifies that the website is
functioning correctly and the entire
architecture is working properly and
once it is then we can continue to
monitor the website on an ongoing basis
and make sure that performance doesn't
degrade over time to check and see what
features users are actually using and
what features that they're not so we can
send that feedback back the development
team so they can make changes as needed
to make sure that we're meeting the
requirements of the customers so
operations team monitors collecting
feedback from the website and doesn't do
as much good to collect that feedback if
we don't have an easy way to push that
feedback back into the team that built
the solution in the first place so some
tools that we can use to collect that
monitoring information to collect that
ongoing usage information are Splunk
Nagios and new relic tools I'm sure
you've heard of before
for monitoring on the enterprise scale
and being able to collect that log
information to collect that monitoring
information that those key metrics and
display them in an easily consumable way
so basically monitoring is that process
of detecting examining and reporting if
there are any faults or threats in the
entire infrastructure so not just with
the hardware but also with the operating
system with the software that's running
on that operating system with any of the
containers with the network with the
memory anything that might impact in a
negative way the execution of our
solution
be collected and alerted on using our
monitoring tools so Nagios allows you to
monitor the server and check and see if
there are any underutilized resources or
if there any tasks failures that need to
be addressed or any other critical
issues that might cause a negative
impact to the service of our customers
so basically Nagios has a plugin that we
install that allows it to load resources
or log data or alert information from
those remote servers and send them to a
central location where they can be
aggregated and displayed through the web
interface this allows operations team
members that are monitoring those
systems and production to easily see and
aggregate that data so they don't have
to go and look at individual reports
from every single server that they're
responsible for if there's a problem
then the tool will notify the admin
about the status or of whatever resource
is having an issue
[Music]
and in this demo we are going to
demonstrate some of the uses of the
common commands and get so we're gonna
use get version to check our get version
I will use get help to list some of the
help commands there and then we'll use
get commit get add get an it and get
status to manage a basic git repository
so let's go ahead and get started you
can see I'm on my C Drive and I get
repos folder here so I'm just gonna
right-click and say get bash here open a
bash command prompt here and we'll
increase the size of the font so you can
see it better there and here we'll start
with just get version and see I'm
running get version 2.2 1.0 for windows
and to see what's in this folder we'll
do an LS as you can see the folder is
empty I do not have any repositories yet
so I'm gonna do a make directory and
I'll make a directory called hello Java
C I've got my hello Java folder now so I
will change directory into the hello
Java folder and here we'll do a get
status to see if this hello Java folder
is a repository no it is not a
repository yet because we just created
it so we're gonna do a git init to
initialize this repository and you can
see now at the end of the command prompt
here we have master indicating that we
are in a git repository and we are on
the master branch so now if we run a get
status it says we are on branch master
there are no commits yet and there is
nothing to commit so let's create a new
file and we'll create the file hello dot
Java C we have that file now I'm not
gonna bother with the vim editor in here
I'll show you why in just a few minutes
here but I'm gonna go into my hello Java
folder and I'm just gonna edit this file
using notepad and I'm just gonna create
a very basic class here in my class is
going to be called hello so um
to create a public class hello and my
public hello class is going to have a
single public static method that's no
static correctly that returns no values
and is called mate this method accepts
string array as the argument list all
this function is going to do is simply
print something to the console so this
will print hello world to the console so
we're gonna do that by doing a system
dot out dot print line and what we're
gonna print is hello world and have a
programming demo without at least one
hello world so there it is so that's our
class I'm just going to save our class
and close the editor here you can see
we've got our hello Java file there the
Windows Explorer again double check that
it's here and we'll do a cat hello Java
to see that we do have those contents of
the file now if we do a git status you
will see that we have our hello Java
with untracked changes so in order to be
able to commit our new Java file to our
repo we're going to have to do a git add
in the name of the file we want to add
in this case hello Java adding it to the
staging area where if we do it get
status we'll see now it's green it's a
tracked change but it still has yet to
be committed to the repository so the
commit we're gonna do git commit now
normally what I want to do is put a dash
in and my commit message but I want to
show you why I didn't use the mem editor
earlier by doing a git commit and it
says hey you have to add your commit
message so here's this text-based editor
for you I'm not really a fan of this
text-based editor but if we start typing
we get the insert command and we can
type add in hello dot Java file and then
we have to hit escape to get out of
insert mode and then we have to type : X
ENTER to save and exit the other case of
creating a file to open notepad to
create the file or in the case of
committing to just
use the - em switch and put your message
right there on the commit line we do our
get status again you can see that we now
have nothing to commit because we have
committed our change already now the
next thing that we might want to do here
is to push our changes to a remote
repository like github but if we try to
do a git push normally we would call
that remote repo origin and we'd want to
push to the master branch we try to do
that without first specifying where that
remote branch is it's gonna give us that
error message and the error message
basically says Origin does not appear to
be a git repository and could not read
from the remote repository make sure you
have correct access rights and the
repository exists make that message a
little more clear if we delete where we
were trying to go we just do a git push
it tells us that we first need to
specify a remote repository using git
remote so if we do get remote add origin
it wants them the URL to our remote
repository so to get to that what we'll
do here is we will launch a new instance
of the browser and we will go to github
on github here we are going to first
create a new repository call our new
repository hello let's call it hello
world
we'll accept all the defaults here and
create our repository and then it gives
us here the URL to our repository so I'm
just going to copy the URL to the
clipboard and then switch back over here
to my git remote add and I'm going to
paste in the URL to that repository now
I have a reference to my remote
repository and now we should be able to
successfully commit our changes to that
remote repository but before we do that
let's take a look at the repository you
can see this repository has no files in
it it's completely empty it says we can
create a file or upload an existing file
or import code from another repository
all we are gonna do is complete our git
push to the origin master
enter and after a few seconds here
you'll see that our push completed
successfully and we can switch back to
the browser and do a quick refresh and
you can see that our one file hello dot
Java has been added with our commit
message added hello dot Java file or
class in parentheses so at this point we
have created a file added it to our
local repository and then pushed that
file to our remote repository where we
then might be able to share that file
with other developers or other team
members working on this solution we are
going to do another demo here on Jenkins
and in this demo we are going to first
create a basic Jenkins job to run a
Windows batch command and then we'll
build another Jenkins job that pulls a
very simple Java class from github and
builds that Java class and executes it
as part of our Jenkins job so first
thing let's take a quick peek at Jenkins
here and in Jenkins a couple of key
locations that you're gonna want to be
aware of are the manage Jenkins area
here and inside of manage Jenkins we
have the area where we can do our mobile
tool configuration and this is where we
would set up tools like maven for
compiling our solutions the JDK for
accessing job there's our maven access
if we want to set up docker containers
as part of our Jenkins jobs we'd also
want to set up a reference to our docker
installation here we're gonna do a
pretty basic demo so we won't have the
need for any of these tools but if we go
back to our dashboard and then back to
manage Jenkins there's also an area here
where you can manage the plugins that
are installed in Jenkins now I here
shows the updates that are available in
since I just installed Jenkins and
loaded all the updates there are no new
updates available but if we click on the
installed tab you can see all of the
default or rather recommended plugins
that Jenkins loaded after installation
after installation it will basically ask
if you want to do a manual installation
of just the plugins that you want or if
you want Jenkins to go ahead and install
the recommended plugins and
this is what you get if you install the
recommended plugins for our purposes in
a later demo we'll be using the get
plugin and you can see here that's
installed by default as part of that
recommended setup okay so we're gonna
start by creating a new Jenkins job
pretty basic Jenkins job here and we're
gonna call it hello Jenkins let's see
I've done this before
we're gonna set that as a freestyle
project so we can build it from scratch
and in this demo we're not gonna pull
anything from github we're just gonna
send a very simple command and so we're
gonna scroll down to the build step and
we're gonna add a build step called
execute Windows batch command and in
this windows batch command we are just
gonna echo something to the console
where we're gonna say hello from the
Jenkins job and we're also going to
display the date and the time that this
request came in and then we'll go ahead
and save that
and now when we go and build this
project very quickly we get a success
because there wasn't much to execute and
then if we click on the build there we
go look at the console output you can
see that we successfully ran this job
and print into the console hello from
the Jenkins job Wednesday three twenty
twenty nineteen fifteen thirty nine and
twenty nine point nine six seconds
success so let's up the ante a little
bit let's go back to the dashboard and
now we'll build another new project this
project will call this one yeah you
guessed it hello github and again we'll
make it a freestyle project so we can
build from scratch and we're gonna tell
it that we're getting this code that we
want to build from our remote repository
so it's gonna want the URL to our remote
repository just so happens I have that
open over here we're gonna get our hello
world repository here so I'm gonna grab
the clone or download and copy the link
to the repository
once I have that link I can come back
over here and to get hub I'm sorry into
Jenkins and I can paste that link to my
github repository now if your repository
requires authentication you'll want
go and add that credential in your
Jenkins credential provider and add
those additional credentials that you
want to use here
leave I've already added the credential
for that github account so all we need
to do now is just add our build step and
our build step in this case is again
going to be a Windows command your
windows batch command i'm gonna do java
c for the java compiler and we want to
compile hello dot java and then we want
to run using the java runtime the hello
java class that we just created so now
we can go ahead and save and then we can
now build this job a small delay while
we compile and the blue sphere there
means that we were successful with our
compile and run of this job and if we go
and look here in the console output we
can see that we compiled our java hello
and then we executed our java hello and
got hello world on the console that
concludes our Jenkins demo and in this
demo we are going to install puppet and
the puppet agent on three nodes in AWS
so to that end we'll create three
instances in our AWS console here we'll
start with the puppet master instance
and we'll create that on an 'm bluetooth
server and we're gonna use a t2 medium
with dual-core CPUs and four gigabytes
of ram yeah we're gonna put it into a
security group that has all ports open
so we don't have to deal with any
firewall issues and we'll just double
check in the instance details subnet
usage will let it go ahead and create
its own subnet here and then we'll
review after it's created to make sure
that our other nodes end up in the same
subnet as for tags here we're just gonna
add a new name tag and we're gonna say
puppet master and then we will launch
the server and use the oregon key here
since we are using the Oregon data
center go ahead and launch that instance
and we'll view this in
since again just to review the subnet ID
that it's on and it's on subnet with the
last three characters of 4d 4 so now
we'll go ahead and launch our two nodes
again using Ubuntu server this time
we're just gonna use the T to micro one
CPU one gigabyte RAM because it's in our
free tier eligible tier so we'll go
ahead and again set the security group
to everybody all in you and lunch and
then we'll update in the instance
details the number of nose we're going
to get two nodes this time twelve to
nose this time and then the subnet I'm
going to use that for the four subnet so
that we can access the master node and
then we'll add a tag name tag called
puppet nodes and review and launch and
we'll launch those nodes again with the
organ heat and we'll launch those
instances all right so if you view our
instances we've got our puppet master
and I'm gonna edit these names here and
call this puppet nose one and we'll call
this one puppet nodes too just so we can
keep track of which is which now first
things first here we want to connect to
our puppet master using putty and to do
that we're gonna use its public IP
address and then we'll go launch putty
here I've already got a setting here for
puppet master but we need to paste in
that updated IP address and then just to
make sure that we are using the correct
key if there's our organ key now we can
go ahead and connect but before I
connect I'm gonna go ahead and save that
and now we have a connection to our
puppet master then that our nodes are up
will connect to the public IP of our
puppet node one again using putty agent
connection here paste in our proper IP
address and again just double check to
make sure we're using the right
certificate and we're not so let's
change that to our or again key and
again we'll save that so
we can reference it usually later I'm
gonna move this window over here and
then go and connect to node2 using its
public IP and again to puddy we'll use
that same agent setting we shouldn't
have to double check and make sure that
the certificate is correct because we
just saved it just in case anything's
gone horribly wrong yes we see we're
using the same or again I'm not gonna
save this one I'll just switch the IP
back and forth we have a connection to
our second node so we now have node 1
node 2 and our master node over here so
now we can begin to add our settings so
first up on our puppet master we are
going to set its hostname to puppet
we're going to do that using the
hostname CTL set hostname command we're
going to do that using a superuser do
and set that hostname to puppet now
we'll do the same on the nodes setting
them to puppet agent and puppet node
respectively but before we do that let's
go ahead and edit our hosts file so that
we can tell the system what the local IP
address is for our puppet master I have
to do this we're gonna go back over to
AWS we're gonna grab our puppet master
and grab its private IP address then
we'll jump back over to our puppet
masters host file I will paste in that
IP address along with the name of our
server puppet then we'll use control X Y
and enter to save that file now we'll do
the same on each of our puppet nodes
will first set our agent to puppet agent
and then we will set our node to puppet
node and then we'll go back and edit the
hosts file on each of those machines and
again we're going to grab that private
IP for our puppet master and we'll
include that as well as the name of that
server and we'll do the same down here
and then control X yes to save the
changes enter to say to that file name
troll X yes to save the changes and
enter to save that file date so now that
we've got the basic DNS info set
we can continue on with installing
resources on these servers so to do that
we're first gonna do sudo apt-get update
to update the package repository and
we'll do that all three of the server's
here first on the puppet master then on
the agent then our rather than on node 1
then on node 2 and once our update is
complete we will then do a double you
get to set the puppet labs installation
repository and since we'll need to
install the puppet master on the puppet
master obviously and then the puppet
agent on each of our nodes will use this
same statement on all three nodes so W
get HTTP colon slash slash apt dot
puppet labs comm slash puppet labs -
release - PC 1 - X e in I al dot DB go
ahead and execute that master on node 1
and node 2 then after that we want to
reference the package again on all three
nodes
seto dpkg - i puppet labs - release - pc
1 - x key in IL d eb and we'll execute
that on all three nodes as we'll need
access to that repository to install
both the puppet master as well as the
puppet agent on all of our nodes and
then we'll do a get update to update our
package repositories again again on all
three nodes we'll do that and finally on
the first node we can go ahead and
install the puppet server so we'll do
that with a superuser do apt-get install
puppet server - why obviously that's
gonna be a little bit different than
what we do on the puppet agent on our
nodes so on those additional servers
we're going to execute superuser do act
yet install puppet - agent so puppet
agent this time instead of puppet server
so you don't apt-get install puppet -
agent - why we'll do that on both of our
nodes here and then we'll jump back to
our puppet man
so that on our puppet master we can
complete the configuration by editing
the puppet server configuration file and
we'll do that but the super user do
using the Nano editor to edit etc' slash
default slash puppet server now in this
file we need to modify the Java args so
we can adjust the memory allocation for
our puppet installation or change that
from two gigabytes down to 512 megabytes
so do that by adding XMS 512 m and X M X
512 m to the Java args and then again
we'll control X yes to save and enter to
save to this file now that we've got the
memory configured we can go ahead and
start puppet server and to do that we'll
use systemctl start puppet service
superuser do systemctl start puppet
server and once we've started the puppet
server then we can go ahead and enable
it for auto start when the system starts
back up again
and then before we can go any further on
our agents we'll want to set up a
manifest file to install something on
those agents and for this demo we'll do
something pretty simple and
straightforward we'll go ahead and
install maven so that we can later build
Java projects but first let's enable our
puppet server for auto start now our
server is up and running we can check
the status of our server using systemctl
status puppet server check and make sure
our puppet server is up and running we
can see here that is active it's up and
running that means we can now go ahead
and add our maven manifest file so we'll
do that this time using the vehm editor
and we'll do that with the superuser do
them and then the path to our manifest
etc' puppet labs slash code slash
environments slash production so we're
working with the production environment
here and in the production environment
we have a manifest folder that we are
going to create a file called maven dot
PP in now in this file we're going to
specify a node configuration for
default nodes so that's every node that
we encounter we're going to set up a
package the Maven package to be
installed so we're going to ensure that
that package is installed then we'll
close our package reference as well as
closing our node configuration and then
we will ex enter to save that file all
right so now that we've got our manifest
file over there we can go to our -
puppet nodes and on those puppet nodes
we can edit their puppet configuration
files so that they can reference the
environment that we want to install our
configuration from so we're gonna edit
using nano again using the path ETCs
last puppet labs slash puppet slash
puppet config and in this file we are
simply going to add a reference to a
main section and then we'll include
certain name it'll set the cert name in
this case to puppet - no node 1 and then
the server equal to puppet in the
environment equal to production and
again we'll control x and y to save and
enter to save to that file we'll do the
same down here on node 2 and again we'll
create a main section we'll add a
reference to the cert named puppet -
node 2 this time and then the server
will still be puppet and the environment
will be production and one more time
we'll control X yes and enter to save
the file now that we've got that set up
we can go ahead and start our puppet
agent service so we'll do that with the
same command that we used earlier sudo
systemctl start puppet this time instead
of puppet server both servers and then
we'll configure those servers or auto
start and just to make sure everything
is doing what it's supposed to be doing
we'll try to tell net to the puppet
server and see there that we have
successfully connected to puppet on
private IP the same thing down here on
node to make sure node two is good also
successfully connected to puppet so now
we can go back to our puppet server and
the act of starting the puppet agent
service on each of our nodes should have
sent a certificate signing request to
our puppet master just to make sure that
we have secure communication so let's
take a look at the cert list on puppet
to see if we have a list of two
certificates to do that we're going to
use Super User do opt puppet labs slash
bin and puppet cert list this should
give us a list of the cert requests that
have come in and you can see there we
have one from node one and another from
node 2 now we could either sign these
requests one at a time by adding puppet
node 1 and then puppet node - or we can
sign the requests all at once using this
command Super User do /opt slash puppet
labs slash bin the slash puppet cert
sign - - all that will sign both of
those requests with one command instead
of having to execute two separate
commands successfully sign both of our
cert requests and now we can go and
execute our configuration now before we
do that let's just double check and make
sure maven is not installed here we try
to do an MV n - - version we get a
message that says command MV n is not
found but it can be installed with sudo
app install maven so that tells us very
clearly that MV n is not installed on
either of these nodes so now we can run
a superuser do opt slash puppet lab
slash bin slash puppet agent test and
this will attempt to go out to the
master server the puppet master and
retrieve manifest files that are
configured for this node or in our case
default which is all nodes that connect
and then it'll install whatever is in
the manifest so we'll run that first on
node 1 and then we'll run that same
command on node 2 and you can see that
ran very quickly in point O 4 seconds
now if we run MVN - - version you can
see that maven 3.5 - was successfully
installed on both nodes and that
concludes our demo of puppet running on
AWS
so from this section the key takeaways
are that DevOps is largely an
organization-wide cultural shift it's
mostly cultural there's a lot of tools
there's a lot of technologies that we'll
talk about but for the most part DevOps
is a cultural shift from one way of
doing business from one way of
developing software to a new more agile
optimized way of delivering software and
resources to do that we need tools
obviously so things like version control
we talked about git and github and once
we have some changes loaded into version
control then we also need to have some
system in place that can detect those
changes and then make sure that those
changes haven't introduced defects by
making sure they still compile or build
and after we get a successful compile
making sure that those changes pass the
tests and that automated test that we
have in place don't start failing after
we've made a change and then using those
same tools we want to make sure that we
get that successfully compiled and
successfully tested solution off into an
environment where we can do more
exhaustive testing where the QA team can
do some manual testings and exploratory
testing or do more in-depth automated
testing and then finally we want to move
into an environment where the operations
team can make sure the configuration is
done correctly we can make sure the
infrastructure is in place before we
begin to deploy in an automated way to
those production environments and again
with that deployment we want to make
sure that we're doing it in an automated
consistent and reliable way so we want
to use an automation tool like puppet or
chef or ansible now to simplify the
deployment process and make the
deployment process more repeatable we
can use containerization and
containerization tools like docker to
allow us to deploy in a repeatable
reliable way while minimizing the need
for excessive operating system
configuration or dependency on multiple
virtual machines and finally using log
aggregation tools and monitoring tools
like Nagios since
and elk we can collect all the
information from these multiple servers
on our DevOps delivery pipeline and make
sure that we're alerted instantly if
anything happens that would negatively
impact the service to our customers
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here